so that was anthony blinken biden
secretary of state and the ukrainian
foreign minister together there at the
state department
talking about sanctions the ukrainian
foreign minister thanked the americans
profusely for our full diplomatic
economic and military support of their
country and kind of hinted
that there
isn't full unity within europe uh the
foreign minister said it's one thing to
condemn
but action has to follow a condemnation
so there is there is some splits that
are occurring between the european
powers pete hegseth uh your reaction to
what we saw there at the state
department and what you heard from
president biden this afternoon yeah a
lot of words a lot of talk about
agreements sanctions what i saw in that
in that briefing room was impotence and
resignation
two people resigned to whatever vladimir
putin is deciding to do and and and
anthony blinken talked about laying out
the playbook what have we done we've
laid out the playbook at every step of
what vladimir putin has done except they
it doesn't feel like we've done it as a
as a ref or a coach or even a player
more like an observer
outside of what's happening there
totally resigned because the leverage we
once had which is which is ultimately
energy uh and you know russia supplies
10 of the world's oil a third of
europe's oil 60 of germany's oil back to
ronald reagan we were trying to stop
pipelines from from uh from
the ussr to europe we didn't stop it
donald trump wanted to stop it so they
did have that leverage they do have
those opportunities and so we're just an
observer at this point and we were
talking dana as we were watching where's
the pound the table moment if we will
not allow this to happen this is a
challenge between a what vladimir putin
wants to do and xi ji ping in china a
new alliance that they have a world that
they want to replace and they want to
undo what was a naive western foreign
policy consensus for quite some time
that if you liberalize and you open up
to china or to russia and allow them to
provide your energy democracy and
freedom and other benefits will flow
from that instead autocrats like xi
jinping in china and vladimir putin and
russia have enriched themselves in the
hope of making russia great again and
we're kind of on the sidelines saying
we'll do what we can we'll ratchet up
the sanctions
do you think vladimir putin is concerned
at this moment about a single sheet of
paper or a single sanction that we've
talked about so far and that's why it
all felt very impotent and the american
people are concerned about the price of
gas the president mentioned that he said
you know there's going to be costs
jammed up on to russia but those costs
are also going to hit the american
driver dana listen to this
defending freedom will have cost
for us as well and here at home
we need to be honest about that
but as we will do but as we do this
i'm going to take robust action to make
sure the pain of our sanctions is
targeted at a russian economy not ours
well i don't i don't believe that
at all but um do you think he explained
why
we're going to be paying these costs
well a couple of things on this i think
the energy is the biggest story out of
this um and it's just the backbone of
every economy and for so many years
we've been talking mostly about climate
change and figuring out a way to get to
electric vehicles great goal but you
can't change the law of physics and
fossil fuels are so important to
economies and now we're seeing that play
out russia is actually probably over
dependent on oil and gas for its economy
but we are under dependent and russia is
excuse me europe is a disaster and
they've been told since the reagan
administration don't make yourselves
dependent now what did john mccain call
russia a gas station with nukes yeah but
and also what so but president biden
today is talking about the gas prices
could go up but let's be clear
they were already up okay so we've had
supply chain issues but also there were
policy decisions made by president biden
on his first day in office amongst other
things where they're canceling oil and
gas leases that make us more vulnerable
to these kinds of things and so energy
is the most important thing this is the
price that countries pay when they give
up energy independence and we're seeing
that play out on the world stage a
couple of things that
lincoln said that might be not a pound
the table moment but the last thing he
said was if putin decides to escalate so
will we
okay but then
what does that mean because if putin
doesn't care about sanctions then what
is the next step will we provide aid to
any sort of insurgency i will also point
out that the foreign minister of ukraine
made it clear that the minor incursion
point that president biden made at his
press conference a couple of months ago
was not helpful in any way because that
has also made europe a little bit less
stable last thing is something it's just
an instinct i'm not saying i know
president putin i had a chance to be in
the room with him several times he looks
different to me like this it feels like
something has changed even with the
pandemic i don't know exactly what it is
but i was just reminded that president
macron of france when he met with him he
said something in putin has changed like
something like maybe something up here
maybe something in his gut instinct but
that is kind of what we're dealing with
is a change in his strategic direction
and president biden has said that he is
going to whip putin's butt martha he's
been saying it for years he's got his
number that putin respects him here's
just number three a flashback saying you
know there was no way biden was ever
going to back down to the guy listen
putin knows if i am president united
states his days of tyranny and trying to
intimidate the united states and those
in eastern europe are over
i'm going to stand up to him
okay has he stood up to him yeah well
we'll see how that works out it doesn't
seem like vladimir putin is too
concerned about that comment and and i
just want to touch on what dana was just
saying because this earlier um general
kellogg was talking about this he said
this is not the man meaning putin who i
had several interactions with during the
trump administration something has
changed in him and when you watch i
thought a really interesting exchange
between putin and his spy chief when the
spy chief stood up basically and said
you know uh yes yes i support what we're
doing and he was very flustered and put
and said what do you mean you support
what we're doing he said i support you
know the entry of uh luhansk and donetsk
into the russian federation and he said
that's not what we're doing
they're independent we're declaring
their independence like you're on the
wrong page and it just reminds me of the
kind of
scene that we've seen with prior
dictators like a mob when they start yes
when they start to kind of lose it a
little bit and he's got all these
anniversaries 100th anniversary tomorrow
of the founding of the soviet union he
has said that was the saddest day of
russian history and he wants to put this
empire back together he's you know 73
years old how many more years does he
have to really do this and he senses
that this is his moment so there's a
danger in the air with putin and that is
a very difficult thing to solve with you
know minsk and normandy agreements and
papers because i think he hears that and
goes whatever throw your papers up in
the air this is what i'm doing yeah i
mean
we can only do so much if this guy wants
to do what he wants to do and he's got
the backing of the russian military
where he has it let's listen to a little
bit of the president earlier harold ford
jr and we just kind of get a sense of
his tone
this is the beginning of a russian
invasion of ukraine who in the lord's
name does putin think gives them the
right to declare
new so-called countries
on territory that belong to his
neighbors we still believe that russia
is poised to go much further
in launching a massive military attack
against ukraine hope i'm wrong about
that hope we're wrong about that but
russia has only escalated its threat
against the rest of ukrainian territory
russia's moved supplies of blood and
medical equipment into position on the
border you don't need blood unless you
plan on starting a war
so that's a major piece of intelligence
that the united states has to see that
they're moving blood
i i can't see why he would do that if he
wasn't going in hard
so i don't differ with a lot around the
table but i have a slightly different
perspective on it i think the main point
that's been made here that should be
noted is the point that you just made
martha that dana made first something's
not right about putin here and if indeed
you want to draw the the mobster
gangster uh analogy normally when the
head of a family sh demonstrates a lack
of capacity like that he or she's taken
out in our world it's he men that are
taken out so perhaps there's some
internal which i think all of our
comments have speculated and implicated
that maybe there's not the agreement
amongst all of his deputies that he
wants number two there's been no nation
that has come forward to demonstrate any
support for what putin is doing there's
no question he thought the way he's
handled this and the way he's uh uh uh
uh projected he would handle this would
cause some division within nato you can
listen to any uh sp uh a commentator any
general they all said they've not seen
nato this united there's no doubt
listening to him the other day rewrite
revise and reimagine the end of the cold
war was one of the strangest and most
fascinating history lessons that one
could ever fictionalize about
and he had no
even his own the the group that is
supposed to be his greatest supporters
it was inertia in that room so i'm
encouraged a little bit by that it was
also interesting to see the uk the
ukrainian prime minister foreign
minister he doesn't look like a lackey
for the united states he seems credible
he seems honest he is relentlessly
patriotic about being a ukrainian and
made clear to uh to your points earlier
jesse to to secretary blinken look we're
with you guys we we hope you act all of
this this the histrionics are great but
let's act
i think it's important that blinken and
the ukrainian foreign minister continue
to do these kind of press conferences i
think it sends a message to russia to
the world to america to americans alike
who i don't think we're prepared to send
troops there and i also think the
audience that's also looking at this is
china china has not made not said a word
about this in fact they've said that
they respect sovereign boundaries we'll
see where that goes but to see nato
fortified strong like this and to see us
standing with ukraine and the foreign
minister there in dc but jesse there's
not been anything we can say verbum we
could be critical and i'm fine with that
but he is unflinching in his support of
what we're doing ukrainian foreign
minister is and i think blink and the
president made clear we're unflinching
in our support of them i think that's a
positive right now
so what happens if this thing moves into
not just ukraine what if vlad goes into
poland what if he goes into some of the
baltic nato states
you think
joe biden's going to trigger article 5
and send a massive amount of american
soldiers into eastern europe to defend
uh
estonia do you think that could happen i
actually think he would you think he
will i think i think attack on one is an
attack on all and i think nato if
there's one thing that's bulletproof
about nato it's it's that belief but i i
disagree slightly with what harold said
because i and you mentioned it talk is
one thing you can talk all you want
about being united but when you look at
nato and those nato countries you can't
gut your military to pay for your
welfare state and open up your borders
uh and then believe you can muster the
kind of collective will necessary to
stare down
a maniac who has ambitions potentially
on that continent what are they what is
the 82nd airborne doing right now in
poland as they prepare they're setting
up processing centers for refugees
that's what that's what our soldiers and
border patrol agents do best these days
with invasions they help facilitate
refugees i don't think that vladimir
putin believes his adversaries are
fundamentally serious right now he
doesn't believe the west is a serious
civilization we're running around
talking about genders and and
reparations and all of this he sees us
divided he sees us as self-loathing he's
and as a result he thinks this is his
moment to make an aggressive move
because we may talk about article
article 5 and we should but would the
american people truly support sending
our boys halfway across the world to
fight against vladimir putin i think the
elites would want us to do so the
population in america would probably you
think those oligarchs who have some of
that financing coming their way some of
some of what we're doing you think
they're going to call him i think they
are look we can't have it every which
way and i know that we don't like some
round table like biden don't like
democrats and that's fine but one thing
is clear
he does not have the support i think
putin of everyone he wants in russia he
does not have the old and at the end of
the day we agree with you in this regard
we're not going to take him out with our
military it's going to be an internal
thing that weakens him and i think he's
weakened by that are those troops
you served can you imagine being in one
of those bunkers right now
one of those 190 000 troops in that in
that cold waiting for them to tell you
going to go and perhaps kill russians in
ukraine i think this is a far more
nuanced and complicated thing and i
understand our politics here but i got
to tell you i'm rooting for the
president i know we all are but i'm
rooting for him in a big way and i'm
rooting for blinken as well in these in
these conversations and showdowns
all right uh dana would you like to say
anything before we
wrap it up
one the other other piece of news was
that the foreign minister of
uh russia lavrov was supposed to have a
meeting with lincoln on thursday that is
off because lincoln said he would only
meet if there was not an invasion
now at 8 30 a.m this morning it was only
an incursion but the administration at
902 am finally said it was an invasion
so that meeting is off okay i mean it is
interesting how we've kind of moved the
language martha at first as dana said it
changed it because more uh it got more
intense and then so did the sanctions
last night we had a certain set of
sanctions just on that eastern region
then we went a higher step you heard the
foreign minister say
he expects a lot more sanctions to keep
getting piled on and not give putin a
sense of okay this is as far as we're
going to go i think the language of
minor incursion that the president used
a couple weeks ago was a big mistake
because he he lost the ability last
night to say that and to allow it to to
be true right so in this essence last
night once he had he said that any
invasion had to be called an invasion or
he would have looked weak right so that
got corrected within an hour this
morning uh that wiggle worm was was
eaten up by dropping that phrase when he
did can i ask martha a question about um
just thinking about this on my way here
knowing that you would be here today uh
because you have such a close
relationship with many of the world war
ii veterans and you've you had a chance
to interview them and obviously the cold
war was different than world war ii but
it was an outgrowth of it and you read
gerard baker today in the wall street
journal who said you know we won the
cold war but we then lost it as the west
because we didn't focus and i wonder if
you have any insight as to how people
are actually it's funny because i think
about you know your experience because
um it's something that i think a lot of
americans don't think a lot about and
that is the creation of all of those
nato countries after the cold war right
after the fall of the soviet union when
they were so weak to then build up that
bolster of nato nations right on their
border that really aggravated them right
so was that the best move at that point
it's almost like post-world war ii you
know how much do you beat up germany at
that point you want them to become a
democracy that can thrive after it's all
over and i think that's something that
historically we have to look back at and
say was that a mistake or not to to
incorporate all those nato nations right
on their border right when they were at
their weakest do you think there ever
will be any accountability uh obviously
expanding nato year after year right to
russia's doorstep but also
making the ukrainians give their nukes
back in the early 90s are we ever going
to get any accountability for you know
the world community as the
foreign minister said from ukraine you
know
we we said yes we'll give these back but
we expect you to get it get our back if
we ever get invaded and they've been
invaded twice yeah and we have not and
the world has not supported them the way
they believed they would be supported
yet another lesson that unilateral
disarmament not very effective
surrounded by people who would like to
take your land and there's there's a
litany of other examples where that's
the case you mentioned libya obviously
uh so
when you're staring when you're steering
down the barrel you talk about a guy in
a trench and what are they thinking
about i guess i'd be thinking about it
depends on what trench you're in what
part of ukraine because there's a lot of
different second biggest country on the
huge country with a huge amount of
resources and a lot of leverage because
of where the pipelines currently go i
mean every other pipeline that russia
supplies fuel to europe goes through
ukraine or belarus and russia
effectively controls belarus at this
point so nordstrom one which operates
right now is operational bypasses all of
that and so does so would nordstrom 2
which we shut off i would want to i
would want to
hope that the world's leaders especially
the united states whether we take
military action or not
listen that when an ambitious man says
he's going to do something that we take
it seriously it may sound like the
musings of of someone who wants to
re-establish russia but he is 73 years
old what is his mental state i don't
know but i know he admires vladimir put
vladimir lenin i know he admires the
legacy of the soviet union and would
like to see himself on that same
pedestal and we'll go as far as he needs
to to make that happen i would maybe
mention was one thing about nato to
something that i learned over the years
of being there which is that um it in
history it shows that democracies
usually
don't declare war on each other and
there's a desire
from people who are born free like if we
all believe that you are born with the
inherent belief that you should you are
free individuals then you want to have
self-determination so that's why there
was this all this fight against
communism and socialism because these
countries recognize that the path to
making sure that their citizens have
opportunities and freedom and free will
that was through democracies and so nato
would provide you that protection so
that's why there was a push and i think
i admire countries that really wanted to
join nato because they wanted to be a
part of it why did ukraine want so badly
to be a part of it one they want their
own self-determination they're it's a
young country now a lot of the people
that live there did not live under
russian rule they don't remember that
they don't want to go back to that
necessarily and that's why you see um
the attempts to fight um there's not i
didn't hear a lot of talk today from
and all the words that were spoken the
word freedom i mean is that what we're
talking about here to me that makes it
makes a really big difference now it
doesn't mean that your fights are fought
for you by other people necessarily but
can you be a part of the free world
i i in my
opinion i think we should fight for that
in whatever ways we can the one thing we
have not mentioned and this is a concern
and i think the bite administration
doing pretty well on this so far
hopefully which is putin's capabilities
of wreaking havoc on the world in
regards to cyber attacks
so our water supply and that of ukraine
and the europeans your energy supply
your food supply your ability to do
banking transactions your ability to
just to google whatever you want that is
on the line here well that goes to your
point about
the freedom argument has the president
looked the american people harold ford
jr directly in the eye and said this is
what we're doing in eastern europe this
is why we're doing it and this is what
could happen because we're doing it he
kind of flirted with it with the gas
prices and says oh i have a plan well he
said he's had a plan before and he
didn't have a plan or the plan didn't
work so i don't know if we trust that
but you add cyber that you saw the
market down like 600 points earlier this
afternoon if you have a couple months of
a market like that and gas goes to four
dollars and maybe they hit what they hit
colonial last time we could go a
tit-for-tat with cyber and sanctions
you're coming out of a pandemic where
people are just getting their head above
water
i don't know if this country is ready
mentally financially for something like
that are we ready i hope so
look you don't get an opportunity to
during the lead-up to war to really
prepare as much as you want i think don
rumsfeld got criticized for saying you
go to war with the army you have not the
army you want
so
you know the administration to their
credit have tried to try to warn big
companies and small companies alike
about how not to defend against a cyber
attack but what's your continuity plan
we should anticipate we're going to have
some reaction from this and they should
understand that we will be offensive as
well and i think the president's made
clear uh i definitely i agree with with
dain on this nato thing i i hope i mean
there's a whole history behind this and
we can perhaps that the giving up of the
weapons of ukraine is maybe something we
should look back at but i in terms of
joining nato uh i'm glad all of those
nations did and i i think president
reagan had it best when he said there is
no security or no safety in the
appeasement of evil
and i think this president our president
is doing everything he possibly can
short of sending troops and i i think
pete has a greater perspective on this
than i do uh and perhaps uh perhaps most
around the table um but this president i
think is using every tool and playing
every card it was not a great hand but i
think he's playing it as well as he
possibly can i think that we should
mention president trump and nato
actually because even though he was
criticized for saying oh nito as we like
kind of poking at nato but what he did
is he made nato sit up and take notice
and a lot of those countries did start
to pay more of their contributions into
nato and i understand that the biden
administration wants to say that nato
has never been more united again i don't
know of that because of the energy issue
but president trump i think deserves a
lot of credit for making sure that nato
was one on the radar but that also that
everyone that was in nato was put on
notice that if you want to be a part of
this if it's all for one and one for all
then that means that you have to be
fulfilling your commitments president
trump made that happen and he put
germany on notice too he said you're
getting all your energy from russia and
we're paying to defend you right from
russia that doesn't make a lot of sense
martha here's the president today
talking about what he's doing in terms
of deployments strategically and
defensively with some of our nato allies
watch
today in response to russian's admission
that it will not withdraw its forces
from belarus i have authorized
additional movements of u.s forces and
equipment
already stationed in europe to
strengthen our baltic allies estonia
latvia and lithuania
let me be clear these are totally
defensive moves on our part
we have no intention of fighting russia
we want to send an unmistakable message
though that the united states together
with our allies will defend every inch
of nato territory
and abide by
the commitments we made into nato so
martha when he says that is he saying
that for domestic consumption like you
know i'm not going to drag us into a war
is he telling putin listen we're not
trying to start a war in eastern europe
who is he talking to
well i think that you know echoes of
afghanistan are still ringing in his
ears he just pulled out of one war he
doesn't want to look at the american
people say you know i might be bringing
you into another but there's only one
reason to ramp up your presence in the
nato countries and that's if you think
that there's a chance that putin might
actually go into one of them and so at
that point given everything that we've
said here about nato and article 5
that's the moment when the president
needs to say make no mistake we are
ironclad on article 5. don't even think
about an encroachment in any of these
countries right i mean that that would
be the moment when you would if if you
are you know ascribing to article five
then that's when you have to stand up
and say i think that's what he said
though i think i think he's trying to
speak to putin but the only message
putin's going to get is he's going to
use it as a rationale to go further look
the nato countries are surrounding me
they're going on the offensive he'll use
it for internal propaganda that's true
but he's clearly saying we're not going
boost on the ground in ukraine and you
know this we're completely defensive
there's
i mean it's amazing to me that an
american president says we are just
purely defensive here like why is that i
don't understand why we waited on the
sanctions i feel like i understand that
you thought it would be a deterrent
against it but he'd already escalated so
much he should have been sanctioned
earlier yeah and that's what the
ukrainian foreign minister said right
there too all right we're gonna monitor
this breaking news out of ukraine and
keep you posted hey sean hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else